So you really have to see this Donald Trump
junior is so desperate for time on air,
but also desperate for opportunities to talk about
how his beloved father, the former president,
is just so liked by everyone that he went on
Sean Hannity's Fox News program last night
on which there were multiple segments about
a group of people that came out in Florida
with Trump flags to cheer Donald Trump on
President's Day as Donald Trump drove, I guess,
from golfing back to his resort or something
like that. And this as I was watching this,
I actually almost felt slightly sorry for Don
Jr., who, of course, is just so desperate to
be liked by his dad, but so desperate to try to
keep the party going for lack of a better term.
Check this out. First, you're going to see a
clip here of Sean Hannity claiming that this
group of several, it appears to be several hundred
Trump supporters spontaneously appeared to cheer
on Trump as he returned from golfing.
Now, if you watch the video, you're
going to notice people with gigantic
flags like eight foot, 10 foot flags.
These are not things you can say,
oh, Trump's going to drive through.
I'll just pop into 7-Eleven and get a 10 foot.
Don't tread on me or Marga or Marga or Trump
flag. You have to plan for this stuff. The police
cordons clearly were organized ahead of time
anyway. Nothing about it seems spontaneous. But
here's Hannity saying, look at this spontaneous
thing that just popped up this very day.
Take a look right there. See that video,
see what's on your screen. A few hours ago,
spontaneously, thousands of people in Palm Beach
lined up in support of the former president
as his motorcade traveled through Florida.
I have a question. Mitch McConnell, John Thune,
how come you never had this kind of enthusiasm at
any of your events? Take a look.
A defiant Sean Hannity there saying,
hey, listen, a senator like John Thune, barely
known to anybody. Never had people with flags
cheering them like a former president of the
United States. What a kind of strange flex
that is. But anyway, then that's not all because
income's done, Junior, to talk about the, quote,
totally organic parade of flag bearing
trumpets that appeared. Take a look at this.
When you look at dad coming back from
golf, did you see thousands of people
out of nowhere? Nobody. Nobody organized
it that I could see. Now, certainly nobody
associated with your father that I know of to you.
No, I mean, this is totally organic, and again,
it just shows that the American people are with
Donald Trump, those millions of people. Sean,
I saw it all day. I put up a separate video
even to the one that you posted earlier.
Now, that's it's actually really funny how Hannity
hedges nobody organized thousands of people
and a police presence. Well, no one associated
with your father anyway. And I guess what Sean
Hannity means is that Trump didn't organize
it himself. OK. And Don Jr. really seems to be
struggling with the math there. And you can't you
kept hearing this during the impeachment trial,
actually, the disenfranchisement of seventy four
million people who voted for Trump, a few hundred
or even a thousand people getting out to support
someone in a country of 330 million people
when Joe Biden got millions more votes than
Donald Trump. What mathematical significance
do a few hundred or even a thousand people have
now on the fact they're, of course, lying to you?
There was nothing organic or spontaneous about
this event. It was President's Day yesterday.
People came from relatively far away from that.
For this. They drove with their flags and people
knew about the event starting at least a week
before it was being promoted. There was nothing
coincidental about it. Here's one advertisement
for the event from Rightside Broadcasting Network
starting to promote this well in advance. They
even say, bring your flags, those flags. You can't
just stop in a 7-Eleven or a Walmart and get an
eight foot Trump flag. You've got to plan ahead.
And what's more sad, I mean, listen, there's a
there's a lot of sad stuff going on here. One
thing is like they always have to go further.
They could just go with there was great turnout
on Presidents Day for Donald Trump. OK. All right.
Well, a few hundred supporters came out. That's
great. Why do you have to say it was spontaneous
and it just popped up out of nowhere? Like,
it's completely unbelievable. Obviously, it didn't
pop out of nowhere. But maybe what's more sad.
Is that Donald Trump Jr. is desperate
not just for relevance, but he's so
desperate for dad's approval and that is it.
This is a cycle that repeats itself. We don't
have to get all psychological. But Donald Trump
was desperate for his dad's approval and his dad
treated him terribly. And that's where a lot
of Trump's complex comes from. And it seems to
be repeated exactly between Donald Trump and
Donald Trump Jr. It's all sad, quite frankly,
but it is what it is, as they say. And hopefully
this will at some point kind of wind down